Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History, and now we go over to Port Stanley in the Falkland Islands. Well, the radio station has now been taken over. I still hope that we can get His Excellency the Governor's message to you. Sir, what do you want to... Do you want to speak to the people? What do you want to tell them?
感谢收听《历史余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史余烬》，现在我们将镜头转向福克兰群岛（马尔维纳斯群岛）的斯坦利港。好吧，广播电台现在已经被接管了。我仍然希望我们能将总督阁下的信息传达给你们。长官，你想……你想对大家说点什么？你想告诉他们什么？
Tell the people to wait, turn on their receivers, to wait some minutes. In some minutes the chief is going to communicate to them what we want for the population. Well, just a minute. If you take the gun out of my back, I'm going to transmit that to you. If you take the gun away. But I'm not speaking with a gun in my back. There's an argument going on now between the three Argentines. They've disappeared.
告诉大家稍等，打开收音机，再等几分钟。几分钟后，负责人将亲自向他们传达我们对居民的要求。好吧，稍等一下。如果你把枪从我背上拿开，我就把这个转告给你们。如果你把枪拿开。但我不是在背着枪说话的情况下发言。这三名阿根廷人现在正争执不下。他们消失了。
They've left me alone in this room. That was the Falklands National Radio Station on the morning of the 2nd of April, 1982. And Dominic Sandbrook, that is history in the making, isn't it? Being broadcast out. That is the arrival of the Argentines on the Falkland Islands or Las Malvinas, as the Argentines themselves would call it. And that set in train a very, very dramatic series of events that happened exactly 40 years ago. And I know that you're brimming over like a six-year-old hosting a birthday party with excitement at this.
他们把我一个人留在这个房间里。那是1982年4月2日早上的福克兰群岛国家广播电台。多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，这就是正在创造的历史，对吧？正在被广播出去。那是阿根廷人抵达福克兰群岛——或者阿根廷人自己所称的马尔维纳斯群岛的时刻。这引发了一系列非常非常戏剧性的事件，这些事件正好发生在40年前。我知道你现在兴奋得就像一个举办生日派对的六岁小孩，情绪简直要满溢出来了。
I am. I am. It's a great way to start, Tom, because it's starting such a dramatic moment, such an extraordinary moment, actually, because that guy is Patrick Watts. He is broadcasting to the people of the Falkland Islands, the 1 the 1800 people um on the friday morning and he's basically saying the argentines have landed overnight and as he's broadcasting the argentines burst into the studio and then they have a massive row among themselves waving their guns around in the air and at precisely that moment we can't play the whole clip but precisely that moment the governor of the falklands rings up and says i've got very bad news the odds have arrived and and it's just an absolutely so the whole story of the falklands war it's the 40th anniversary um we were talking about this before we started weren't we tom about how it's a sort of combination of it's it's very
我是。我确实很兴奋。汤姆，这是一个很好的开端，因为它是从这样一个戏剧性的时刻，一个非同寻常的时刻开始的，实际上，因为那个人是帕特里克·瓦茨。他在星期五早上向福克兰群岛的居民，那1800人广播，他基本上是在说阿根廷人在夜里登陆了，正当他广播的时候，阿根廷人冲进了播音室，然后他们在那里大吵大闹，在空中挥舞着枪支，就在那个精确的时刻——我们无法播放完整的片段——福克兰群岛总督正好打来电话说：“我有非常坏的消息，局势已经失控了……” 这绝对是……福克兰群岛战争的整个故事，正值40周年纪念……我们开始之前还在谈论这个，对吧，汤姆，关于它是一种某种结合，它非常
churchillian in some ways or these people think it's sort of Churchill role play for the British. But at the same time, there's this bizarre kind of 1950s comedy aspect to it, which that clip actually perfectly encapsulates. Yeah, it's, yes, it's the finest hour kind of rewritten by the carry on crew or Tom Sharp or Peter Sellers or that level of. And I have to say, Dominic, that the definitive account of this, I mean, you're a wonderful writer, you're a wonderful historian, but the four chapters that you devote to the Falklands War in your most recent history of Britain, Who Dares Wins, Britain 1979 to 1982, I genuinely think is one of the great pieces of of british 21st century writing oh it's it's it's as good as anything in any novel that i've that i've read it's absolutely fantastic and i think you remember
在某些方面很具丘吉尔风格，或者这些人认为这有点像是英国人的丘吉尔角色扮演。但与此同时，它又有一种诡异的20世纪50年代喜剧色彩，那个广播片段其实完美地概括了这一点。是的，没错，这是由“滑稽喜剧”（Carry On）团队或汤姆·夏普（Tom Sharp）或彼得·塞勒斯（Peter Sellers）或那种水平的人重写的“辉煌时刻”。我必须说，多米尼克，关于这件事的权威叙述——我的意思是，你是一位出色的作家，你是一位出色的历史学家——你在你最近的英国史著作《谁敢赢：英国，1979年至1982年》（Who Dares Wins, Britain 1979 to 1982）中专门用来讲述马岛战争的那四章，我真心认为那是21世纪英国写作的伟大篇章之一。哦，它……它和我有生以来读过的任何小说中的任何内容一样精彩，绝对太棒了，而且我想你还记得
that i i was letting you know how much i was enjoying reading um who dares wins when it came out but the honestly if you haven't read it listeners go and get it but actually you won't need to because dominic you're basically going to do it now for us. I am. I am. I'll tell you. I mean, it is a kind of dramatic story. It's a story of military prowess, naval prowess, lots of stuff that's been written about it, focuses on the kind of the military exploits, the technical wizardry that enabled the task force to go all the way from Britain and recapture this kind of rocky outcrop in the middle of the South Atlantic.
我曾让你知道当《谁敢赢》出版时我有多么享受阅读它，但说实话，如果你还没读过，听众们，去买一本吧。不过其实你们也不需要读，因为多米尼克，你基本上现在就要为我们讲一遍了。是的，我会的。我会告诉你的。我的意思是，这确实是一个戏剧性的故事。这是一个关于军事实力、海军实力的故事，很多关于它的著作都聚焦于军事功绩、技术奇迹，正是这些技术奇迹使得特遣舰队能够一路从英国出发，夺回南大西洋中心这处岩石裸露的偏远高地。
But it is also amid the horror and the tragedy in the bloodshed. I mean, it is often a deeply comic story too, and full of extraordinary characters. Yeah, I think that's absolutely true. So Jorge Luis Borges, the brilliant Argentine writer, said it was two bald men fighting over a comb. And, um, Do you know, I've never quite understood what that meant. So, so he basically was arguing that the Falklands were completely useless and trivial and that, um, two sort of spent, shallow opportunistic sort of governments were fighting over them and
但同时，在恐怖、悲剧与流血之中。我的意思是，它往往也是一个极其滑稽的故事，充满了非凡的人物。是的，我想这绝对是真的。因此，豪尔赫·路易斯·博尔赫斯（Jorge Luis Borges），这位才华横溢的阿根廷作家，曾说过这是两个秃子在争夺一把梳子。而且，你知道，我从来没有完全理解那是什么意思。所以，他基本上是在辩称福克兰群岛完全是无用且琐碎的，两个可以说是强弩之末、目光短浅、机会主义的政府为了它们而争斗，
sacrificing people's lives, um, for nothing. And I think that's actually, I mean, he, he had this sort of joke about, you know, the Bolivians have always been crossed because they don't have access to the sea. So why don't we give them to Bolivia to make up for it? But of course, the thing was, there were almost 2,000 people living on those islands, you know, whose future was at stake. Well, who thought themselves to be British.
却为了毫无意义的事情牺牲人们的生命。我认为这实际上——我的意思是，他曾开过这样一个玩笑，你知道，玻利维亚人一直很不高兴，因为他们没有出海口。那我们为什么不把这些岛屿给玻利维亚来作为补偿呢？但当然，事实是，那些岛屿上生活着将近2000人，你知道，他们的命运正处于危急关头。好吧，他们认为自己是英国人。
And were they British? They were. I mean, they were. There were no... So they're British passport holders? Yeah. Well, I mean, they are subjects of the crown. So they're British passport holders? Yeah. Well, they are subjects of the crown. So it's kind of like the Channel Islands or something.
他们是英国人吗？他们是的。我的意思是，他们是。没有任何……所以他们是英国护照持有者？是的。我的意思是，他们是王室的臣民。所以他们是英国护照持有者？是的。好吧，他们是王室的臣民。所以这有点像海峡群岛还是什么的。
Exactly. Exactly. We can go into the whole saga. So let's start at the beginning. So what are these islands just off Argentina? I suppose they're not just off Argentina, are they? I mean, but let's say they're closer to Argentina than they are, to Southampton yeah so so what what is the basis of the British claim all right Auckland Islands let's get into the whole so the Falkland Islands is for those people who don't who have no idea
完全正确。完全正确。我们可以深入探讨整个来龙去脉。所以让我们从头说起。那么这些位于阿根廷海岸外的岛屿到底是什么？我想它们不仅仅是在阿根廷海岸外，对吧？我的意思是，但我们可以说它们离阿根廷比离南安普顿要近。是的，所以——那么英国声索主权的依据是什么？好吧，福克兰群岛——让我们进入整个……所以对于那些完全不知道我们在说什么的人来说，福克兰群岛
what we're talking about it's it's a war fought between Britain and Argentina in the spring of 1982 it's a decisive moment in the history of Argentina its transition to democracy in the spring of 1982. It's a decisive moment in the history of Argentina and its transition to democracy, in the history of Britain and the survival of the Thatcher premiership and in Britain's sense of itself. But as you say, at the center of it are these islands that are just miles from anywhere.
是英国和阿根廷在1982年春天爆发的一场战争。它是阿根廷历史上的一个决定性时刻，是其在1982年春天向民主过渡的决定性时刻。这是阿根廷历史及其向民主过渡的决定性时刻，是英国历史以及撒切尔首相生涯得以延续的决定性时刻，也是英国自我认知的一个决定性时刻。但正如你所说，这一切的核心是这些距离任何地方都有数英里之遥的岛屿。
And that's one of the things that gives this this sort of slight comic opera aspect. So the Falklands, you said they're just off the coast of Argentina and that is what most people think, Tom, if they think they're not in Scotland, which is what everybody thought in 1982. And we'll maybe come back to that issue of whether or not they were in Scotland. So they are 500 miles from Rio Gallegos, which I think is the nearest Argentine city,
这也是赋予了它这种略带喜剧歌剧色彩的因素之一。所以关于福克兰群岛，你刚才说它们就在阿根廷海岸外，大多数人如果认为它们不在苏格兰的话——这正是1982年时所有人的想法——也都会这么想。我们也许会回过头来探讨它们到底是不是在苏格兰这个问题。所以它们距离里奥加耶戈斯（Rio Gallegos）有500英里，我认为那是阿根廷最近的城市，也是最近的大型港口。
the nearest sizable port. So they're not off the coast of Argentina. They're quite a long way off the coast of Argentina, but they're closer to Argentina than to anywhere else. So basically what happens is in the 18th century, these islands which are uninhabited, which are very cold, which do look like Scottish islands or like the Faroe Islands. Except they've got penguins, right? Yeah, they do have penguins, but they're very cold cold they're more more land um they have lots of sheep um but yeah there's there's nothing there's
所以它们并不在阿根廷海岸边。它们距离阿根廷海岸有相当长的一段距离，但它们比世界上任何其他地方都更靠近阿根廷。所以基本上发生的事情是，在18世纪，这些无人居住、非常寒冷、看起来确实很像苏格兰岛屿或法罗群岛的岛屿……除了它们有企鹅，对吧？是的，它们确实有企鹅，但它们非常寒冷，有更多的土地……它们有很多绵羊……但确实，那里什么都没有，没有自然资源，
no natural resources miles and miles of bugger all dennis thatcher said dennis thatcher miles and miles of bugger all so dr johnson talked of their bleak and gloomy solitude charles darwin who who went to the falkland island said was struck by their desolate and wretched aspects their peaty soil and wiry glass of one monotonous brown color so they're not desirable at all but what happens in the 18th century the english arrive first the british rather they see the british discover them the british discover them they basically sail past them so is it is it a lord falkland or somebody who's Admiral Falkland who's leading this expedition? Well, Lord Falkland never goes there. So the first person to go there, I think,
丹尼斯·撒切尔（Denis Thatcher）说过，到处都是荒凉的卵石。丹尼斯·撒切尔说：到处都是荒凉的卵石。所以约翰逊博士（Dr Johnson）谈到它们荒凉而阴郁的孤寂时，查尔斯·达尔文（Charles Darwin）曾造访福克兰群岛，他说自己对它们荒凉而悲惨的面貌、泥炭般的土壤以及单一的棕色铁丝草留下了深刻印象。所以它们一点也不令人向往。但18世纪发生了什么呢？英国人最先抵达，或者说英国人发现了它们。英国人发现了它们，他们基本上从它们旁边航行而过。所以，是福克兰勋爵（Lord Falkland）还是什么人，是海军上将福克兰率领这次远征的吗？嗯，福克兰勋爵从未去过那里。所以第一个去那里的人，我想，或者说第一个以其名字命名的人是一个叫约翰·斯特朗（John Strong）的人，他是一名英国船长。所以刚才我说的是18世纪。实际上，那是17世纪末，1690年。他以赞助他航行的海军司库的名字命名了这些岛屿，那位司库就是福克兰子爵（Viscount Falkland）。哦，原来如此。所以你得到了福克兰群岛这个名字。
or the first person to give their name is a guy called John Strong, who's an English captain. So I said 18th century. Actually, it's late 17th century, 1690. And he names them in the honour of the treasurer of the Navy who sponsored his journey, who was Viscount Falkland. Oh, right. So hence you get the Falkland Islands.
但英国人，或者说英国，并没有在那里进行永久定居。实际上在18世纪发生的事情是，这些岛屿不断易手。我想法国人拥有了第一个真正意义上的永久定居点，而且它们多次易手。这是一个非常混乱、实际上也算不上特别激动人心的故事。但它们最终落入了西班牙手中，
But the English, or rather the British, they don't kind of permanently settle. And actually what happens in the 18th century is the islands just keep changing hands. So the French, I think, have the first real permanent settlement, and they change hands several times. It's a very confusing and actually not an especially exciting story. But they end up with spain um which
这很合乎情理，因为当然西班牙在南美洲拥有大量殖民地，所以有许多西班牙船只经过，因此它们最终落入了西班牙手中。但后来在拿破仑战争期间，西班牙放弃了它们，所以那里没有大规模的定居点——为什么会有呢？你知道的，如果你是一个西班牙人，并且你要去新世界，你会去阿根廷或秘鲁。所以那里没有黄金或任何东西。那里什么也没有。因此西班牙人在拿破仑战争期间离开了，但他们留下了一块牌匾。
makes sense because of course spain has lots of colonies in south america so there are lots of spanish ships passing so they end up with spain but then what happens in the napoleonic wars is that spain abandons them so there's no sort of large-scale settlement there why would there be you know if you're spanish and you're going to the New World, you'd go to Argentina or Europe. So there's no gold or anything. There's nothing there. So the Spanish leave in the Napoleonic Wars, but they leave a plaque.
这在关于这些岛屿主权声索的讨论中非常重要，因为牌匾上写着这些岛屿是马尔维纳斯群岛（Las Malvinas），它们属于西班牙王室。现在，在这之后发生的事情是，在1816年，阿根廷——拉普塔总督辖区或诸如此类的政权——宣布脱离西班牙独立，因为西班牙在拉丁美洲的帝国正在解体。
And that is very important in the sort of the talk of the claim of the islands, because the plaque says these islands are Las Malvinas and they belong to the Spanish crown. Now, what happens after that is that in 1816, the Argentina, the vice royalty of the River Plate or whatever, declares independence from Spain because the Spanish empire in Latin America is breaking up.
当阿根廷基本上成立时，新的阿根廷政府说，好吧，我们获得了西班牙帝国在这个地区的所有领土，这包括福克兰群岛。他们建立了一个非常小的殖民地——我的意思是，我们说的真的是岛上的寥寥数人。所以在19世纪20年代，岛上的人——那个西班牙殖民地——我想他们内部总是分崩离析，只有在那里生活的区区三个人和一条狗。而在1833年——这是一个非常重要的日子，因为1983年将是这件事的150周年纪念——
And when Argentina is basically formed, the new Argentine government say well we get all the possessions of the spanish empire um in this area and that includes the falkland islands and they establish a very small colony i mean we're talking about literally a handful of people on the islands so in the 1820s the people on the islands the spanish colony i think they're always falling apart among themselves, the three men and a dog who were there. And in 1833, very important day because 1983 will be the 150th anniversary of this.
所以，在1833年，英国人进驻了。他们基本上认为这是一个极好的地点，可以让我们建立一个基地，进行补给等等，并且他们确立了永久控制权。他们对岛上的西班牙人做了什么？我不认为这会产生什么实质性的重大影响。所以来自西班牙或阿根廷并没有什么外交抗议吗？来自阿根廷的？哦，阿根廷人不高兴，但他们无能为力。我的意思是，19世纪阿根廷的政治非常动荡。所以阿根廷人将其列为阿根廷政府待办事项清单上的头等大事。
So in 1833, the British move in. They basically think this would be a tremendous spot for us to have a sort of base you know refueling all this sort of stuff um and they establish permanent control and what do they do with the spanish people who are on it i don't think it makes a much a really substantive difference so there isn't some kind of diplomatic protest from spain or from argentina from argentina oh the argentines don't like it but there's nothing that much they can do about it i mean the argentines argentina's politics in the 19th century is very turbulent. So the Argentines, it's not number one on the Argentine government's kind of to-do list.
而且，难道不是吗，在19世纪，事实上一直延续到20世纪，阿根廷可以说是英国的一个非官方殖民地？完全正确。所以阿根廷与英国关系的整个历史真的非常非常有趣。因此，阿根廷是英国的一个非正式殖民地。它与英国的商业利益、航运有着各种各样的联系。显然，牛肉出口对阿根廷来说至关重要。这也是他们学习足球的方式。足球，橄榄球。
And also, isn't it right that in the 19th century, and in fact, right the way into the 20th century, Argentina is a kind of unofficial colony of Britain? Exactly. So the whole history of the relationship between Argentina and Britain is really, really interesting. So Argentina is a kind of informal colony of Britain. It's got all kinds of links to British business interests, shipping. Obviously, the export of beef is massively important for Argentina. And that's how they learn football. Football, rugby.
还有板球。马球、板球、绅士俱乐部。布宜诺斯艾利斯应有尽有。所以在19世纪末，如果你是一个英国绅士，一个受过公学教育的英国绅士，你可以去布宜诺斯艾利斯，感到完全像在家一样，就像你去印度、澳大利亚或类似的地方一样。那里有绅士俱乐部，有人打马球，有人看橄榄球，正如你所说，你知道，河床队。
And they did cricket. Polo, cricket, gentlemen's clubs. Buenos Aires has them all. So at the end of the 19th century, if you are an English gentleman, public school educated English gentleman, you can go to Buenos Aires and feel completely at home as you would do if you went to India or Australia or somewhere like that. There are gentlemen's clubs, there are people playing polo, there are people watching rugby, there are, as you say, you know, River Plate.
我的意思是，布宜诺斯艾利斯的两大足球俱乐部之一的名字本身就是英文的，这说明了一切。所以阿根廷与英国的这种关系并不少见，并且与这些国家现在与美国的关系非常相似：一方面，它让人感到英国性是一种象征地位和声望的东西，人们希望穿英国风格的西装，他们想打马球；但与此同时，也有一种怨恨情绪，
I mean, the very name of the football club one of the two great football clubs of um of buenos aires is is in english um which tells its own story so argentina has this relationship with britain that is not uncommon and is very similar to the relationship the countries have now with the united states so on the one hand it's it it feels britishness is a sort of it connotes status and prestige and people want to have their British style suits and they want to play polo but there's also a bit of resentment
特别是在社会阶层较低的人群中。我想如果你不了解阿根廷的历史，你就无法理解福克兰群岛发生了什么。好吧，福克兰群岛上只有很少的人。我想人口在两次世界大战之间达到顶峰，大约有3000人，他们全都是牧羊人。这就是那里仅有的全部工作了。
at the same time especially as you go lower down the social spectrum and I think you don't understand what happens with the Falklands if you don't understand what happens with the history of Argentina so right, the Falkland Islands there are very few people on them. I think the population peaks at about 3,000 in the interwar years, and they're all sheep farmers. That is all there is
但在大英帝国和日不落帝国的背景下，它具有重要意义吗，在战略上具有重要意义吗？虽然英国拥有帝国，因为还有……还有一座名为南乔治亚岛的岛屿，对吧？它更深入大西洋，这在整个故事中也起到了作用。是的，还有南图勒（Southern Thule）——这是一个多么浪漫的名字——它甚至更远。南图勒在斯坦利以南1200英里，我想南乔治亚岛在斯坦利以东大约800英里。我的意思是，南乔治亚岛因其在沙克尔顿——伟大的南极探险家——的故事中所起的作用而闻名，但我的意思是，这些岛屿真的不仅仅是南极探险的前进基地吗？其实并不是。但它们在第一次世界大战中确实发挥了作用，不是吗？有一场海战，是的，没错。
to do. But in the context of the British Empire and Britannia ruling the waves, is it significant, strategically significant, while Britain has an empire because there's also also uh there's an island called south georgia right which is even further out into the atlantic and that also plays a part in this story yeah there's also southern thule which is even that's a such a romantic name which is even further away southern thule is 1200 miles south of stanley and i think south georgia is about 800 miles east of stanley i mean south georgia is famous for the role it plays in shackleton um the the great antarctic explorer but i mean is it are these islands really anything more than a forward base for antarctic exploration not really not really but they they play a role in the first world war don't they uh there's a
所以在发生战争、发生海军战争的情况下——是的，这些是很重要的。第一次世界大战中有各种各样的阴谋诡计，搜寻德国船只以及诸如此类的连串事件。但这通常只在战争期间才真正重要。你知道，如果你从事捕鲸业，那么南乔治亚岛非常好；如果你从事南极探险，如果你想把它留在那儿，也许你想有一个基地来补充燃料等等，但没有它你也可以生活得很好。我的意思是，这并不是说它是某个宏大的地缘政治“风险”游戏（Risk）的核心部分。
battle yes and yes exactly so so in the event of of a war of a naval war so yes these are important there's all kinds of you know um sort of uh shenanigans in the first world war sort of searching for german ships and all this kind of carry on but that only really matters in the event of a war generally you know if you're into whaling then south georgia is very good if you're into antarctic exploration if you want you want to have it there possibly you want to have a base to refuel and stuff but you can live perfectly well without it i mean it's not like this is a central part of some colossal geopolitical game of risk so going going into the post-war years as the british empire fades, as colonies get given up,
所以进入战后岁月，随着大英帝国逐渐黯然失色，殖民地被放弃，英国海军实力退缩，福克兰群岛就像是一个地缘政治上的盲肠或尾骨。它就像是一种……它完全就是这样。所以它们实际上没有任何用途。它们是史前故事的遗迹。它完全就是这样。所以，汤姆，这并不罕见——我的意思是，太平洋上到处都是岛屿，法国有很多岛屿，法国有很多这样的岛屿，美国也有，我是说关岛或者别的什么——你甚至可以说夏威夷是一个大得多的……我们谈论过夏威夷，不是吗？那可能应该属于英国，我们当时在扮演盎格鲁人。是的，基本上发生的事情是，如果你——
as British naval power retreats, the Falkland Islands are a kind of geopolitical appendix or coccyx. They're a kind of… That's exactly what they are. So they don't really serve any purpose. They're the remnants of a prehistoric tale. That's exactly what they are. so and that's not uncommon tom i mean the pacific is littered with islands the french have a lot of them the french have lots of them the americans do i mean guam or whatever i mean you could argue hawaii is is a much bigger well we talked about
不需要为此深入探讨帝国主义，发生的事情是人类在地球的各个角落大规模扩张，在19世纪，欧洲殖民帝国基本上夺取了每一个微不足道的环礁，如果可以的话，他们建立了一个据点，在福克兰群岛插上一面旗帜，他们确实这么做了，然后有些人开始去那里牧羊。现在，有些人已经在那里生活了好几代人，他们距离任何地方都有数英里之遥——我的意思是，他们不想要独立，他们不能独立，因为他们不能自给自足，一切都必须进口。
hawaii didn't i mean that should probably be british it should we were playing anglicans yeah i mean what's basically happened is if you uh it's no need to to delve too deep into imperialism for this what's happened is the human race has expanded massively of every corner of the earth and in the 19th century european colonial powers have basically taken every little sort of two-bit atoll they've established if they can planted a flag a little planted a flag in the falklands they they've done that and then some people have turned up to farm sheep now some people have been there for generations they are hundreds of miles from anywhere um i mean they don't want independent
好吧，所以我们——假设我们到了1980年，对吧？这是一个巨大的跨越。是的，请继续。我想我们确实必须在不到10期播客的时间内讲完这一切。大约有2000人。是的，1800人。全都是英国人，他们世世代代都在那里。所以我的意思是，他们自1833年起就在那里了，其中一些人是这样的。有些人是，但并非全部。所以福克兰群岛上无事可做，因此如果你年轻，你知道，你常常想离开——所以是的，有一个众所周知的情况是，那里有一个非常小的皇家海军陆战队驻军，所以姑娘们会嫁给皇家海军陆战队士兵然后离开，因为他们是……
they can't have independence because they're not self-sufficient everything has to be imported okay so we so we let's say we get to 19 1980 right that's a big leap. Yeah, go on. I guess we do have to get through this in less than 10 podcasts. There are about 2,000 people. Yeah, 1,800. All of them British, who are going back generations. So I mean, they've been there since 1833, some of them. Some of them are, not all of them. So there's nothing to do on the Falkland Islands so if you're young you know you can't often you want to get out so yeah there's a there's a famously what happens is that sort of there's a very small Royal Marine garrison and so the girls marry the girls marry the Royal Marines and go off because they they're the bright lights of you know
切尔姆斯福德（Chelmsford）或其他地方的繁华都市。在你的书中，你引用了BBC拉丁美洲记者的言论，谈到福克兰群岛时他说：“酗酒现象严重，离婚率高，女性短缺”，这并没有……不，这确实……好吧，但是多米尼克，我的意思是，尽管如此，当我们审视这背后的政治、地缘政治时，我的意思是，这些人在那里生活了将近150年，这些岛屿一直属于英国，这是一个事实。所以这比许多国家还要悠久。当然。所以，
Chelmsford or whatever in in your book you you quote the bbc latin america correspondent talking about the falklands and he says a lot of drunkenness a high divorce rate and a shortage of women which doesn't yeah no it doesn't really okay but dominic would i mean it is it is nevertheless when we look at the politics of this the geopolitics of this i mean it is a fact that these people have been there and that these islands have been British for almost 150 years. So that's older than many countries. Yeah, of course. So,
嗯，同时也没有少数族裔。所以没有土著居民，也没有任何类似……这并非某种北爱尔兰之类的地方。没有任何社区想要与阿根廷合并。是的。正如我们一会儿将要看到的，岛民坚决反对与阿根廷合并。是的。我的意思是，正如我们一会儿将要看到的，
um, there's also, there's no minority. So there's no indigenous people and nor is there, nor is there any sort of, you know, this is not kind of, um,
岛民坚决反对与阿根廷合并。现在，对于阿根廷人来说，随着20世纪的推移，福克兰群岛的分量越来越重，不是出于任何战略原因，也不是因为哪个阿根廷人真的曾访问过福克兰群岛，而是因为它成了这样一种象征。一个图腾。
Northern Ireland or something. There's no, there's no community that wants union with Argentina. Yeah. The, I mean, as we'll, we'll see in just a second, the Islanders are dead against any union with Argentina. Yeah. I mean, as we'll see in just a second,
它是否专门充当了摆脱英国统治的图腾？也就是说，那种具有压迫性的英国文化和经济影响的遗产——所以从某种意义上说，你知道，我们在伊朗或俄罗斯身上也能看到这一点，即英国拥有一种与其江河日下的地位不相称的恶名。完全同意。完全同意。我认为对英国的怨恨本身就是某种事物的简写，那就是阿根廷拥有一段非凡的历史，因为它进入20世纪时曾是世界十大最富裕国家之一，
the islanders are dead against any union with Argentina. Now, for the Argentines, the Falklands have loomed larger and larger as the 20th century has gone on, not for any strategic reason, not because any Argentine really has ever visited the Falklands, but it's this kind of symbol. A totem.
而且是一个似乎注定要在20世纪大显身手的国家。我的意思是，它拥有极其赚钱的牛肉产业。它拥有布宜诺斯艾利斯这座飞速扩张的欧洲风格城市。意大利移民源源不断涌入。一切似乎都一帆风顺。然而阿根廷却度过了一个糟糕透顶的20世纪，这是任何人都没有真正预料到的。因为第一次世界大战导致食品价格崩溃，而且从未真正恢复，它被各种不稳定因素撕裂，
And does it specifically serve as a totem of casting off britain so so that kind of legacy of of oppressive british cultural and economic influence that and so in a sense you know and we see the same with iran or with russia that britain has a notoriety above its straightened station. Agreed. Agreed. I think the resentment of Britain is a kind of shorthand in and of itself for something else, which is that Argentina, it's got an extraordinary history because it had entered the 20th century as one of the world's 10 richest countries
所以大约从20世纪40年代和50年代开始，当时你有了胡安·庇隆（Juan Perón）——这位民粹主义民族主义者、艾薇塔（Evita）的丈夫——他曾挥舞着福克兰群岛的旗帜，他基本上说过，阿根廷遭到了肢解。你知道，我们的一部分生斯权利被这些……他们总是称我们为海盗的人夺走了。就像德雷克（Drake）那样。是的，被这些偷走了马尔维纳斯群岛的英国海盗夺走了。在它们被归还之前，我们永远不会完整。在20世纪40年代末和50年代，布宜诺斯艾利斯会出现广告牌或海报，
and a country that appeared set fair to be a real player in the 20th century. I mean, it's got this beef industry that is incredibly lucrative. And it's got Buenos Aires, which is a massively expanding European-style city. Italian immigrants pouring in. Everything seems set fair. And Argentina then has an awful 20th century, which nobody had really expected. Because the industry in which food prices collapse because of the first world war and they never really recover and it becomes torn apart by all kinds of instability
上面写着：“英国海盗，把马尔维纳斯还给我们。”正如你所说，它成了一个图腾。随后，阿根廷迎来了绝对堪称人间地狱的20世纪70年代。所以曾经被驱逐的庇隆在1973年、1974年卷土重来。他当时已经有点残破不堪了，他去世后，他的妻子伊莎贝尔（Isabel）成为了阿根廷的领导人，随后她被军方推翻，接着他们就迎来了军政府，即阿根廷军政府。他们对本国人民发动了一场肮脏的战争，
so from about the 1940s and 50s when you had juan perron the sort of populist nationalist you know husband of evita he had brand he had waved the flag with the Falklands, and he basically sort of said, Argentina has been mutilated. You know, we have been part of our birthright has been taken from us by these. They always would call us pirates. So like Drake or something. Yeah, by these English pirates who have stolen that Las Malvinas. And we will never be whole until they are returned. And there would be billboards or posters in the late 1940s and 1950s
他们把人从飞往大西洋上空的直升机上扔下去，他们枪杀和折磨诗人和异见人士——这就是豪尔赫·贝尔戈里奥（Jorge Bergoglio，后来成为教皇方济各）身处的背景。是的，他当时是那里的耶稣会会长，而他们之间的关系……有很多争议。我认为你成功把基督教扯进来了，汤姆。我只是——我觉得这很重要。但是，多米尼克，我可以宣读一位顶级历史学家对军政府将军们、军政府军官们的评价吗？请便。
in Buenos Aires saying, you know, English pirates, give us back the Malvinas. And so it sort of, as you say, it becomes a totem. Argentina then has this absolutely hellish, hellish 1970s. So Perón, who had been kicked out, he comes back in 73, 74. He's a bit of a wreck he dies his wife isabel becomes um leader of argentina she's then kicked out by the army and then they have the junta and the the argentine military hunter so they are presiding over a dirty war against
他们非常擅长发动政变、戴着墨镜和谋杀异见人士。但在某些情况下，他们唯一的战斗经验就是对左翼诗人的生殖器施加电刑。多米尼克，那位顶级历史学家不是别人，正是在下。正是在下。没错，就是我。《谁敢赢》？所以，我的意思是，这基本上概括了他们。他们不是好人。他们绝不是好人。你书中最精彩的主题之一就是，如果你想在20世纪80年代发动一场殖民战争——一个看起来殖民战争已经不再是你会参与的那种事情的时期——
their own people they are kind of throwing people out of helicopters over the atlantic ocean they're shooting and torturing poets and dissidents and this is the backdrop um to uh to jorge bergoglio who later becomes pope francis yeah he's head of the jesuits there and he is indeed relations are kind of much debated i think you've you've done well to get christianity in tom i just well i thought it was important but um dominic, could I read a top historian on the generals of the junta, the officers of the junta? Yeah, do. They were very good at launching coups, wearing sunglasses and murdering dissidents. But in some cases, their only experience of combat had been to apply electrodes to the genitals of left-wing poets. And Dominic, that top historian was none other than yourself. It was myself.
阿根廷军政府基本上是理想的选择。我的意思是，他们太糟糕了。他们是可怕的人。正如你所说，他们折磨和残害左翼人士……他们不太擅长打仗，对吧？我的意思是，他们没有丰富的战斗经验，他们除了自己人之外从来没有真正跟任何人打过仗，而且他们有点荒诞，他们具有那种荒诞的喜剧色彩。他们确实有，但同时也非常阴险。是的，非常阴险。
Yeah, it was me. Who dares win? And so, I mean, that basically sums them up. They're not good guys. They're not good guys. And one of the themes that you bring out brilliantly in your book is the way in which, I mean, if you wanted to have a colonial war in the 1980s, a period where it would seem that colonial wars are not the kind of thing that
所以他们自70年代中期以来一直当权，他们统治着一个基本上处于城市状态的国家——你甚至可以称之为低烈度的内战，这种游击运动，即“蒙东内罗斯”（Montoneros），他们安放炸弹、绑架人以及搞所有这些类似的事情。他们的通货膨胀率也达到了——我的意思是，疯狂的水平。所以，你知道，达到了三位数。这正在让中产阶级陷入贫困。
you go in for, the Argentine junta is basically ideal. I mean, they're terrible. They're terrible people. They torture and maim, as you say, left-wing yeah um they're not very good at fighting are they i mean they haven't had a huge amount experience of it they have never really fought anybody other than their own people um and they're kind of grotesque they have that kind of grotesque comic comic quality they do but sinister at the same time yeah very sinister yes so so they have been in since the mid 70s and they're presiding over a country where there's basically an urban, you could almost call it a low-level civil war, this kind of guerrilla movement, the Montoneros, who are setting up bombs and kidnapping people and all this kind of stuff. They also have inflation that is, I mean, crazy levels. So, you know, three digits. And so that's impoverishing the middle classes.
完全正确。但同时，我的意思是，对于工人阶级来说，由于物价一直在上涨，买任何东西都变得不可能。罢工问题层出不穷。所以他们面临着这样一个经济上的烂摊子。他们拥有某种意识形态，任何熟悉拉丁美洲战后政治的人都会知道，这种意识形态带有相当浓厚的法西斯主义色彩。所以这一切都关乎国家、男子气概——
Exactly. But also, I mean, also it's impossible to, for the working class, it's impossible to buy anything because the prices are going up all the time. There are constant problems with strikes. So they've got this kind of economic basket case. And they have an ideology, which anybody familiar with Latin American post-war politics will know, which is quite fascistic. So it's all about kind of the nation manhood
受到诗人、左翼分子和共产主义者的威胁。当然，美国正在大把大把地砸钱来维持这些政权，因为他们对共产主义恐惧万分，他们拥有所谓的“秃鹰行动”（Operation Condor），这全是为了训练他们的秘密警察、训练他们的情报部门来镇压异见人士等等。这非常见不得光。我的意思是，“肮脏战争”这个标签绝对名副其实。因此，加尔蒂埃里将军（General Galtieri）在1982年初成为了军政府的领导人。是的，1982年之交，正是如此。
threatened by you know poets and and left-wingers and communists and the americans of course are right pouring money in to keep those because they're terrified of communism and they have this kind of operation condor which is all about you know training their secret police training their intelligence services in in suppressing dissent and all this. It's very dodgy. I mean, the Dirty War label is well-deserved. And so General Galtieri, who becomes head of the Junta in early 1982. Yeah, the turn of 1982, exactly.
所以他是军政府的负责人——顺便说一句，军政府内部发生了什么呢？他们之间存在军兵种之间的竞争。所以陆军、空军、海军，他们有点互相仇恨——陆军、空军、海军，他们有点互相仇恨，这加剧了混乱。是的，所以加尔蒂埃里——他有意大利血统，但在西点军校受过训。我知道，他在西点军校受过训。他们都非常亲美。所以马岛战争的一个潜台词是，阿根廷人绝对确信美国会支持他们，他们根本没有想过美国不会支持他们。所以加尔蒂埃里在82年初上台。
So he's the head of the – what's happened in the Junta, by the way, is they have inter-service rivalries. So the Army, the Air Force, the Navy, they kind of hate eachservice rivalries so the army the air force navy they kind of hate each other and that adds to the chaos yeah so galtieri who's um of italian descent but trained at west point i learned trained at west point and he they're all very pro-american so one of the subtexts for the balkans war the argentines are absolutely convinced that the americans will back them it is it doesn't occur to them that the Americans will not back them. So Galtieri is coming in at the beginning of 82.
所以实际上阿根廷军队——我在书中没有过分深入探讨这一点，但这是故事中一个如此迷人的方面——阿根廷军队在20世纪70年代末就想要一场战争，但实际上英国并不是他们的首选。他们的首选是智利。智利，是的。他们恨智利人，对吧？智利人也恨他们，这也将成为故事中重要的一部分。在局外人看来，那些政权看起来几乎一模一样：你在智利有皮诺切特将军（General Pinochet），在阿根廷有加尔蒂埃里和他的亲信们，但他们彼此极其鄙视，
And so actually what the Argentine armed forces, I didn't really go into this massively in my book, but this is such a fascinating aspect of the story. The Argentine armed forces wanted a war at the end of the 1970s, but actually Britain wasn't their first choice. Their first choice was Chile chile yeah they hate the chileans don't they and the chileans hate them and that's going to be an important part of the story too to outsiders those regimes look pretty much identical so you've got general pinochet in um in chile and you have galtieri and his chronicronies in argentina but they absolutely despise each other and the
阿根廷人真的想因为比格尔海峡（Beagle Channel）和火地岛（Tierra del Fuego）的边界划分问题与智利打一仗。我的意思是，那真的将是……的定义。所以，但这有点像是美国支持的法西斯分子想要互相残杀。所以他们不能支持智利那些美国支持的法西斯分子，于是他们选择了英国那些美国支持的法西斯分子，对吧？
argentines really wanted to have a war with Chile about the Beagle Islands and the division of the border in Tierra del Fuego. I mean, that really would be the definition of... So, but it's kind of American-backed fascists wanting to fight one another. So they can't back the American-backed fascists in Chile, so they choose the American-backed fascists in Britain, right?
哦，太棒了，汤姆。好吧，很好。这就是年轻人的风格。既然如此，我们有了以加尔蒂埃里为首的领导层，他在西点军校受过训，受到美国支持；然后我们有了……海军司令豪尔赫·阿纳亚（Jorge Anaya）上将。是的，加尔蒂埃里根本没有头脑，所以他们是好朋友，对吧？他们从军校时期起就是朋友了。而阿纳亚是军政府的智囊，他在82年初基本上对加尔蒂埃里说，你知道，政权一团糟，阿根廷的经济一团糟，我们需要做的是，我们显然需要一个极具民粹色彩、大快人心的手势。
Oh, very good, Tom. Okay, right. Very good. That's the young ones style it unless so we've got galtieri at the head he's trained at west point he's american-backed and then we have um admiral jorge anaya who is head of the navy yeah he's galtieri has no brain at all so they're pals aren't they they've been pals since their days at military college and anaya who is the um he is the uh he's the brains of the hunter and he basically says to galtieri at the beginning of 82 you know the regime is a shambles the economy is a mess in argentina what we need to do is we obviously need a very crowd-pleasing gesture
从现在算起的一年内，将是那些海盗偷走马尔维纳斯群岛150周年纪念日。所以我们可以在他们之前把这些岛屿夺回来。他之所以这么认为，是因为他看着英国，看到的是一个基本上陷入混乱的国家。是的，好吧，这正是另一个方面，不是吗？所以我们谈完了阿根廷，谈完了福克兰群岛，我们应该……那么我们现在休息一下。等我们回来时，我们将审视福克兰群岛入侵前夕英国的政治背景。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
and in any one year from now it will be the 150th anniversary of the moment when these pirates stole the Islas Malvinas. So we can get these islands back before them. The reason he thinks that is because he looks at Britain and he sees a country basically in chaos. Yeah, well, this is the other aspect, isn't it? So we've done Argentina, we've done the Falklands and we should... So let's take a break now. And when we come back, we will look at the political context in Britain in the build-up to the invasion of the Falklands. I'm Marina Hyde.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
大家好，欢迎回到《历史余烬》。我们正在讨论福克兰群岛战争，正如我们在2022年3月下旬录制这期节目时所知，这场战争正好发生在40年前。这个迷你系列将分为四集播出，第二集将在明天（也就是周二）播出，第三集在周四播出，最后一集将在下周一（也就是4月4日）播出。当然，如果你等不及了，并且你是《历史余烬》俱乐部（Restless History Club）的会员，你现在就可以收听全部内容。访问 restlesshistorypod.com 即可加入。现在让我们把目光转向英国。在1982年，它的处境并不愉快。没有。为什么阿根廷人会选择……为什么他们认为自己可以侥幸入侵
Hello and welcome back to The Rest Is History. And we are talking about the Falklands War, which happened exactly 40 years ago as we record this in late March 2022. This miniseries will stretch out over four episodes, with episode two coming tomorrow, that's Tuesday, episode three on Thursday, and then the final episode next Monday, so next week, on the 4th of April. Although of course, if you can't bear to wait for that, and you're a member of the Restless History Club, you can listen to the whole thing already. Restlesshistorypod.com to join. Now let's look at Britain. It's not in a happy place in 1982. No. Why do the Argentines choose, why do they think they can get away with invading
福克兰群岛或将其从英国手中夺走？好吧，他们和所有人一样看着英国，认为英国是个彻底的烂摊子。所以英国发生的事情可以这么说，是长达14年的巨大政治和经济动荡。我的意思是，我知道对于70年代是辉煌还是糟糕，人们有不同的看法。但英国的英镑已经贬值。它经历了一系列因与工会冲突而倒台的政府。它接受了国际货币基金组织的救助。它经历了没完没了的罢工问题以及政府与工会之间的摩擦。它面临着北爱尔兰问题和爱尔兰共和军（IRA）的炸弹袭击キャンペーン等等。撒切尔夫人在1979年夏天当选，作为第一位女首相、保守党人，她带着这种用猛药来治愈沉疴的承诺上台。而实际发生的情况是，在前两年半的时间里，一切似乎都变得不可衡量地更糟了。所以我们做过一期播客。我们早期的播客之一就是关于1981年的。
the Falklands or snatching them from Britain? Well, they look at Britain, as everybody else does, and they think Britain's a complete basket case. So what's happened in Britain has been, let's say, 14 years of tremendous political and economic turbulence. I mean, I know people have different views about whether the 70s were brilliant or whether they were terrible. But Britain has devalued the pound. It has had a series of governments that have fallen after conflict with the trade unions. It has had a bailout from the International Monetary Fund. It has had endless problems with strikes and trouble between the governments and the unions. It has got the issue of Northern Ireland and the IRA bombing campaign and so on. Mrs. Thatcher was elected in the summer of 1979, first woman prime minister, conservative, on this sort of promise of radical medicine to cure the disease. And what's actually happened is that the first sort of two and a half years, everything has just appears to have got immeasurably worse. So we did a podcast. One of our early podcasts was about 1981.
1981年的英国是一个相当糟糕的年份。失业率飙升、骚乱、内城骚乱、北爱尔兰的爱尔兰共和军绝食抗议。尽管有板球……我们一起战胜了澳大利亚。那是伊恩·博瑟姆（Ian Botham）的“灰烬杯”，没错。但总的来说，从政治上讲，那是一个充满巨大动荡的时期。对大多数人来说，玛格丽特·撒切尔显得像是一个变数，一个异类。
1981 in Britain is a pretty awful year. Unemployment through the roof, riots, inner city riots, IRA hunger strikes in Northern Ireland. Although the ashes. We did beat Australia together. It was Botham's ashes, exactly. But by and large, it's been politically a time of enormous turbulence. Margaret Thatcher, to most people, appears an aberration, an anomaly.
你知道，这个疯狂的女人，她的支持率达到了民调历史上空前绝后的低谷。所以她是自1981年底有记录以来最不受欢迎的首相。保守党在民意调查中排在第三位。出现了一个名为社会民主党的新政党，该党在民意调查中处于领先地位。我想，如果你是一个阿根廷将军，你看着英国，然后你会说，好吧，英国很虚弱。它失去了帝国。它经历了混乱的过去10年。它有这个疯狂的女人——我的意思是，一个女性担任首相，简直不可思议。英国人显然绝不可能
You know, this mad woman whose popularity has reached depths unprecedented in polling history. So she's the most unpopular prime minister since records began at the end of 1981. The Conservatives are in third place in the opinion polls. There's a new party called the Social Democratic are in third place in the opinion polls. There's a new party called the Social Democratic Party, which is leading the opinion polls. And I think if you're an Argentine general, you look at Britain and you say, well, Britain is weak. It lost its empire. It's had a shambolic last 10 years. It has this mad woman. I mean, a woman as prime minister, unthinkable. There is obviously no way that the British
采取任何行动。而且就算他们尝试了，谁在乎呢？没有人会支持他们。他们只是一个死去的、你知道的、破产的空壳。撒切尔夫人和她的政府显然正在努力做的事情之一就是削减开支。国防部——当时正处于冷战时期，所以国防开支相当大——撒切尔夫人发起了一项审查，我没记错吧，这项审查特别针对海军？好吧，他们必须削减某些东西。所以由于她的政治需要，她迫切希望削减开支。
will do anything. And even if they try to, who cares? No one will back them. They're just a dead, you know, busted flush. One of the things that obviously that Mrs. Satcher and her government are trying to do is to claw back on spending. And the Ministry of Defence, this is the Cold War, so there's quite a lot of spending on defence. Mrs Thatcher has initiated a review, am I right, that particularly targets the Navy? Well, they have to cut something. So she's desperate to cut spending because of her political
无所不用其极。而且就算他们想这么做，谁在乎呢？没有人会支持他们。他们只是个彻底完蛋、你知道的，已经破产的无用之物。撒切尔夫人及其政府显然正试图做的事情之一，就是削减开支。而国防部——当时正处于冷战时期——因此有相当大的一笔国防开支。撒切尔夫人已经启动了一项审查，我没说错吧，这项审查特别针对海军？好吧，他们总得削减点什么。因此，由于她的政治压力，她迫切希望削减开支
and economic agenda and to sort of cut Britain's deficit. And in January 1981, she has brought in this guy called John Knott, who I know you like this line, Tom. He looks like a man who should have been a Bond villains accountant. I do like that line. But had been in Malaya. Is that right? In the Gurkhas. He'd been an officer in the Gurkhas.
以及经济议程，并试图削减英国的赤字。1981年1月，她提拔了一个叫约翰·诺特的人，我知道你很喜欢这句台词，汤姆。他长得就像一个本·韦恩的反派会计师。我确实很喜欢这句台词。但他曾在马来亚待过。是这样吗？在廓尔喀部队。他曾是廓尔喀部队的一名军官。
As I learned yesterday from Twitter when I put this out, Tony Hart, who was on Vision On. Yes. I mean, nothing to lots of listeners. No. The guy who would instruct children on how out. Tony Hart, who was on Vision On. Yes. That would mean nothing to lots of listeners. No, the guy who would instruct children on how to draw Tony Hart programs. How to paint and draw. I felt that it was very, even at the age of sort of four or five,
正如我昨天在推特上发了这个消息时从托尼·哈特那里了解到的，托尼·哈特曾出演过《Vision On》。是的。我的意思是，这对很多听众来说毫无意义。没有。那个会教孩子们如何画画的人。托尼·哈特，曾出演过《Vision On》。是的。这对许多听众来说可能毫无意义。不，那个教孩子们如何画画的托尼·哈特节目。如何画画和素描。我觉得它非常，即使在四五岁的时候，
I felt that it was too worthy. And I really wanted to be watching, obviously, Paddington, Tom. Well, I was a big fan and his best friend was a a plasticine man called morph called morph yeah but anyway this we're slaloming off off piste here yeah so let's so but one of the reasons why i mentioned john not who i mean he absolutely does look like a kind of villainous accountant you're completely right and a lot of the kind of tory grandees in mrs thatcher's cabinet
我觉得它太一本正经了。我真的很想看，当然是帕丁顿熊，汤姆。嗯，我是他的超级粉丝，他最好的朋友是一个叫莫夫的塑胶泥人，叫莫夫，是的。但不管怎样，我们在这里有点偏离正题了，是的。所以，让我——不过我提到约翰·诺特的原因之一，我的意思是，他绝对长得像那种邪恶的会计师，你完全说对了。撒切尔夫人内阁中的许多托利党大人物，
do they you know thick glasses yeah kind of balding spindly uh you feel you know they wouldn't be be a good hand in the fight but almost all of them have won the military class or something right in the second world war I mean they so so lots of the people with Mrs Thatcher in Mrs Thatcher's government are are war heroes they are decorated war heroes Willie Whitelaw Lord Carrington all the sort of lord carrington is lord carrington is foreign secretary willie whitelaw is home secretary so we'll come to carrington in a second because he's really important but on not so john not has been told i mean this by the way will be music to the to the ears of argentina's government if they'd sort of been following if they've been reading all this so not basically is told cut defense
你知道吗，戴着厚厚的眼镜，嗯，有点谢顶，身形瘦长，你会觉得，你知道，他们在打架时可不是什么好手，但几乎所有人在第二次世界大战中都获得过军功章什么的，对吧？我的意思是，撒切尔夫人身边的许多人，在撒切尔夫人的政府里，都是战争英雄，他们是功勋卓著的战争英雄，威利·怀特洛，卡灵顿勋爵，所有这些，卡灵顿勋爵是外相，威利·怀特洛是内政大臣。所以我们一会儿再谈卡灵顿，因为他非常重要。但关于诺特——所以约翰·诺特接到指令，我的意思是，顺便说一句，如果阿根廷政府一直在关注、一直在阅读所有这些报道，这听起来对他们来说简直是天籁之音。所以诺特基本上接到指令，削减国防
spending they have the choice of cutting the army in west germany the british army in the rhine or the navy and their basic attitude is precisely as you say tonkis is the cold war well we need the army on the rhine but the navy is neither here nor there so he says well let's get rid of most of the fleet we'll shut the dockyards we'll get rid of we've got three aircraft carriers we'll get rid of two of them hermes and invincible we'll close the dockyards in Gibraltar. We'll shut a lot of the stuff in Portsmouth. Get rid of it. You know, just close it all down.
开支。他们面临的选择是削减驻西德的军队——驻莱茵河的英国陆军，还是海军。他们的基本态度正如你所说，汤基斯，那是冷战时期，嗯，我们需要莱茵河上的陆军，但海军是无关紧要的。所以他说，好吧，让我们裁掉大部分舰队，关闭船厂，裁掉——我们有三艘航空母舰，裁掉其中两艘，“竞技神”号和“无敌”号，关闭直布罗陀的船厂。关闭朴茨茅斯的许多设施。统统裁掉。你知道，全部关掉。
And one of the things that they say, well, let's get rid of, is this ice patrol ship, very important, called the Endurance, which is basically like an antique that just sort of potters around by the Falkland Islands. It's this sort of – It's barely a deterrent. It's a totem of deterrence rather than a deterrent in itself. But Lord Carrington, who is the Foreign Secretary, he does understand that this might signal a certain degree of weakness to Argentina.
他们说要裁掉的项目之一，就是这艘非常重要的、名叫“坚忍”号的极地巡逻舰，它基本上就像一件老古董，在福克兰群岛附近慢悠悠地转悠。它有点像——它几乎算不上威慑力量。与其说它是一种威慑，不如说它是威慑的象征。但是外交大臣卡灵顿勋爵确实明白，这可能会向阿根廷发出某种软弱的信号。
And he does kick up a fuss. And you say about this that the decision to scrap endurance which mrs satchel goes ahead with was one of the most expensive she ever took because effectively it serves to green light the invasion is that is that right yeah so i suppose the um the analogy that i give is um that it's like getting rid of a burglar alarm on your house. If there are burglars on the other side of the road watching, and you come out and very publicly start to dismantle your burglar alarm. Now, you could say, I mean, the burglars are still at fault,
他也确实大发雷霆。而你对这件事的评价是，撒切尔夫人继续推进的废弃“坚忍”号的决定，是她做出过的最昂贵的决定之一，因为它实际上等同于为入侵开绿灯，是这样吗，是这样吗？是的，所以我想我给出的比喻是，这就像是拆掉你房子的防盗报警器。如果马路对面有小偷在盯着，而你走出来，非常公开地开始拆除你的防盗报警器。现在，你可以说，我的意思是，小偷依然有过错，
and you still have the right not to be burgled. But you would argue it's foolish. That's basically what Lord Carrington, the Foreign Secretary, says. We shouldn't get rid of it, even if it's a bit – it's not that expensive. He says it's cheaper than having the Argentines invade. Now, the thing is, Lord Carrington, since he became Foreign Secretary in 1979, has been saying to his government colleagues, I think the Argentines, they're rattling their sabres a little bit too loudly. I don't think deep down he really believes the Argentines, you know, they're rattling their sabres a little bit too loudly. And I don't think deep down he really believes the Argentines are going to invade because that would
你仍然有不被盗窃的权利。但你会认为这是愚蠢的。这基本上就是外交大臣卡灵顿勋爵所说的话。我们不应该裁掉它，哪怕它有点——其实花不了多少钱。他说这比让阿根廷人入侵要便宜。问题是，卡灵顿勋爵自1979年担任外交大臣以来，一直对政府同僚说，我认为阿根廷人，他们的叫嚣有点太厉害了。我想他内心深处并不真的相信阿根廷人，你知道，他们的叫嚣有点太高调了。而且我认为他内心深处并不真的相信阿根廷人会入侵，因为那
just be such a lunatic thing to do. But he sort of says, they could, you know, we should be on our guard. Now, some listeners will, especially overseas listeners, and if we have Spanish speaking listeners, will be saying, oh, the Brits, they just, you know, they're dyed in the wool imperialists just clinging on to their colonies this is absolutely not the case with the falkland islands they're desperate to get rid of them we have we were desperate to get rid of them because they're expensive you have to keep sending them stuff they're miles away and they don't really you know we don't need more sheep and we don't need wool isn't there a plan to to give all of them a million pounds well Well, that comes later on. To persuade them to leave.
实在是太疯狂了。但他还是说，他们可能会，你知道的，我们应该保持警惕。现在，一些听众，特别是海外听众，如果我们有说西班牙语的听众，会说，哦，英国人，他们只是，你知道的，他们是冥顽不灵的帝国主义者，死死抓着自己的殖民地不放。福克兰群岛的情况绝对不是这样的，他们迫切想要甩掉这个包袱。我们迫切想要甩掉它们，因为它们太贵了。你得不停地给它们运送物资，它们远在天边，而且说实话，你知道的，我们不需要更多的羊，我们也不需要羊毛。难道不是有一个计划，给每个人一百万英镑吗？好吧，那是以后的事了。为了说服他们离开。
That comes later on, yes. One of Mrs. Thatcher's key economic advisors, Alan Walters, did say later on, it'll be much cheaper if we give them each a million pounds and get them to leave than fight to get their islands back for them. So Britain wants to do business with Argentina. So the foreign office is – when the foreign office looks at this, they say, listen, we want to trade with Argentina. So the foreign office is, when the foreign office looks at this, they say, listen, we want to trade with Argentina.
那是后来的事了，是的。撒切尔夫人的主要经济顾问之一艾伦·沃尔特斯后来确实说过，如果我们给每个人一百万英镑让他们离开，比打仗把群岛夺回来要便宜得多。所以英国想和阿根廷做生意。因此，外交部——当外交部看到这一点时，他们说，听着，我们想和阿根廷做生意。所以外交部是这样的，当外交部看到这一点时，他们说，听着，我们想和阿根廷做生意。
They're actually a friendly country because they're on our side in the Cold War. The Falklands issue is getting in the way and it's much better. Persuade the Falkland Islanders who rely on Argentina anyway. If you need medical treatment, you're flown to Buenos Aires.
他们其实是一个友好的国家，因为他们在冷战中站在我们这一边。福克兰群岛的问题一直在从中作梗，最好还是这样。说服那些无论如何都依赖阿根廷的福克兰群岛居民。如果你需要治疗，你会被飞机送到布宜诺斯艾利斯。
The flights go through there. They get stuff from Buenos Aires. Why don't we just persuade them that it's in their interests to have a relationship with Argentina? And they basically cook up this plan in about 1980. And the plan is they know that the islanders don't want to just be handed over. So Mrs. Thatcher sends one of her junior ministers, a guy called Nicholas Ridley, very famous for smoking
航班从那里起飞。他们的物资来自布宜诺斯艾利斯。为什么我们不能说服他们，与阿根廷保持关系才最符合他们的利益？他们在1980年左右大致炮制了这个计划。计划是这样的：他们知道岛民不愿意就这样被移交给别人。于是撒切尔夫人派了她的一位初级大臣，一个叫尼古拉斯·里德利的人去，他以抽烟闻名，
and not liking the Germans. Yeah, and the grandson of the architect is Edward Lutyens. Edward Lutyens, exactly. So very aristocratic. They sent him over to the Falkland Islands, and he's got to sell the islanders this thing, which is basically they'll do a deal with Argentina where Argentina will get sovereignty over the Falklands, thing which is basically they'll do a deal with the with the with argentina where argentina will
而且不喜欢德国人。是的，建筑师爱德华·鲁琴斯的孙子。爱德华·鲁琴斯，没错。所以非常有贵族气派。他们把他派到福克兰群岛，他必须向岛民推销这套方案，基本上就是他们要和阿根廷达成一项协议，阿根廷将获得对福克兰群岛的主权，方案基本上就是他们要和阿根廷达成协议，阿根廷将
get sovereignty over the falklands but they'll basically rent them out to britain to administer for them so that the islanders can still feel that they're being run by the british and that the union jack is flying and stuff and that'll be like a 99 year lease or something so argentina yeah like hong kong but argentina will be able to say oh we've got them back they're as yeah and and ridley goes over and he has this sort of public meeting and people say no you know they don't like it um we don't want to be argentines we hate the argentines we hate you and he's fabulously rude he is very rude he says kind of a posh nicotine smoker. So he basically says, at one point, there's an amazing exchange. So somebody shouts from the audience and he says,
获得对福克兰群岛的主权，但他们基本上会把群岛租给英国，由英国代为管理，这样岛民们仍然能感到自己是由英国统治的，米字旗还在飘扬等等，这将是一个为期99年左右的租约。所以阿根廷——是的，就像香港一样。但阿根廷将能够说，哦，我们把它们收回了，它们就像——是的。里德利去了那里，他召开了这样一场公开会议，人们说不，你知道，他们不喜欢这样。我们不想成为阿根廷人，我们讨厌阿根廷人，我们讨厌你。而他极其粗鲁。他非常粗鲁。他有点像个讲究的上流社会烟民。所以他基本上在某个时刻说了一句，有一段精彩的对话。有个观众大声喊道，
what are you going to do if the Argentines invade? And Ridley says, I'll kick them out. And they all laugh at him mockingly. And he says, well, we would kick them out if they invaded. But then he goes on to say, he says, well, that's not the issue. He says, the problem is, do you want the Argentinians invading you and us kicking them out in a state of perpetual war it's all very well sitting here saying someone else must come and kick the argentinians out of course we would but is that good for sheep farming for fishing for looking for oil for your futures for your children
如果阿根廷人入侵，你们打算怎么办？里德利说，我会把他们赶出去。大家嘲弄地大笑起来。他接着说，好吧，如果他们入侵，我们确实会把他们赶出去。但随后他继续说道，他说道，好吧，这不是重点。他说，问题是，你们是希望阿根廷人入侵你们，然后我们处于永久战争状态中把他们赶出去吗？坐在这里说别人必须来把阿根廷人赶出去，这倒是轻而易举，我们当然会这么做，但这真的对养羊、捕鱼、寻找石油、对你们的未来、对你们的孩子、
for your grandchildren or great-grandchildren is that the way you want to live this is what you've got to think about so he explicitly says this to the islanders and the islanders basically say get out we hate you we want to stay british and when he leaves do you know what they do as his as his plane is leaving they have a they mount a loud speaker land of hope and glory this land is our land and we shall not be moved right so a triumphant diplomatic foray do you think it might have worked out differently if he'd been more of a diplomat because he's i mean he's notoriously i mean he gets sacked he gets sacked later on doesn't he for insulting chancellor cole yeah calling him a nazi yeah he does um he said the the european union was a german racket to take
对你们的孙辈或曾孙辈有利吗？这就是你们想要的生活方式吗？这就是你们必须思考的问题。所以他明确地对岛民们这样说，而岛民们基本上回答说：滚开，我们讨厌你们，我们要保持英国国籍。当他离开时，你知道他们做什么吗？当他的飞机离开时，他们架起了一个大喇叭，播放着《希望与荣耀的土地》（Land of Hope and Glory）——这土地是我们的土地，我们绝不离开，对吧？真是个凯旋而归的外交远征。你认为如果他更像个外交官，事情会不会有不同的结果？因为他——我的意思是，他出了名的——他被解雇了，他后来被解雇了，不是吗？因为他侮辱了科尔总理，是的，称他为纳粹，是的。他确实——他说欧洲联盟是德国人接管欧洲的诈骗集团，
over europe um i think i know i actually think even if they'd sent someone more emollient the falkland islanders would have eaten them alive i mean the falklanders are farmers and they are they're sort of plain speaking but also here's the thing it's not just atavism and sort of you know prejudice that the falklanders don't want to be argentinian the argentines at the moment that ridley is speaking are kind of electrocuting you know folk singers and kicking people out of helicopters into the atlantic ocean so the infallible say what the hell why would we want to be part of by the have that regime in charge okay okay so so um the the the aspiration of the british government to save money
呃，我想——我其实觉得，即使他们派去一个更温和的人，福克兰群岛人也会把他生吞活剥的。我的意思是，福克兰人都是农民，他们说话直来直去。而且，还有一件事：福克兰人不想成为阿根廷人，这不仅仅是因为返祖现象和某种偏见。在里德利发表讲话的时候，阿根廷人正在电击福克兰歌手，把人们从直升机上扔进大西洋。所以福克兰人会想：见鬼去吧，我们怎么会想成为那种政权的子民？好吧，好吧。所以，英国政府试图通过裁减南大西洋的海军力量来省钱，并试图说服福克兰人妥协，我想，这再次加剧了布宜诺斯艾利斯的一种感觉，即英国人不会插手，他们根本不在乎。他们不会为此开战。英国人连极地巡逻舰都要裁掉。于是他们开始筹备入侵。但就在这时——这也正是喜剧和闹剧元素介入的地方——
by getting rid of the um the naval forces in the South Atlantic and trying to persuade the Falklanders to go over, I guess, again, must kind of add to the sense in Buenos Aires that the British are not going to, they don't really care. They're not going to fight over this. The British are getting rid of their ice ship. And so they start to prepare an invasion. But then there is, and this is kind of where the element of the comic and the farcical intrudes.
我们提到了南乔治亚岛。那里发生了什么？就在阿根廷海军筹备入侵之际。这太诡异了。这真的太诡异了。所以阿根廷海军在1982年初基本上制定了这个计划。他们计划在年底动手。
We've mentioned South Georgia. What happens there? Just as the Argentinian Navy is preparing its invasion. This is so weird. This really is so weird. So the Argentine Navy basically construct this plan in the early months of 1982. What they want to do is they want to attack in the latter part of the year.
那时天气非常糟糕，因为南大西洋的季节与北半球相反，他们希望在天气极其恶劣的时候动手。而且当时英国的国防裁军刚刚开始发挥效力。这样英国就无法派遣特遣舰队去收复群岛。如果他们真的这样做了，汤姆，我想事情可能就这么定局了。
So when the weather is so bad, because obviously the seasons are reversed in the South Atlantic, they want to do it when the weather is so bad. And obviously British defence cuts will start to be kicking in. So the British cannot send a task force to retake the islands. And had they done so, Tom, I would say that probably would be it.
因为英国需要很长时间才能组建起特遣舰队，到那时肯定会出现某种外交妥协。嗯，而且到那时群岛早就被严重巩固防守了。是的，当然。所以从阿根廷的角度来看，这是一个毋庸置疑的决定。但极其怪异的是，他们要赶在1983年周年纪念日前完成，这样街头就会挤满人群。那太棒了。极其诡异的是，阿根廷海军的一个独立分支
Because what would happen is that such a long time would elapse before the British could then get a task force together, that there'd be some sort of diplomatic fudge. Well, but also the islands would be so strongly fortified by that. Yeah, of course. So it's a no-brainer from the Argentine point of view. But completely bizarre, and they'll do it in time for the 1983 anniversary, so they'll have crowds on the streets. It'll be great. From the completely bizarrely, a sort of separate part of the Argentine Navy
决定在南乔治亚岛也搞一次这种噱头。正如我们所说，南乔治亚岛距离数百英里，是英国南极考察队的基地。因为他们决定他们也想要那个地方。他们打算怎么做呢？南乔治亚岛过去一直是捕鲸重镇。那里有很多废弃的捕鲸站和石油加工设施，到处都是废铜烂铁。70年代末，一个叫康斯坦丁诺·达维多夫的阿根廷人向英国外交部申请说，
decides that they'll also mount this sort of stunt on the island of South Georgia, which is, as we said, hundreds of miles away, and is the base of the British Antarctic Survey. Because they decided they'd like that as well. And what they'll do is, South Georgia was always very big for whaling. And there's a sort of whaling station and oil processing stuff just lying about, loads of scrap metal. At the end of the 70s, an Argentine guy called Constantino Davidoff basically applied to the British Foreign Office and said,
我能来把这些废铁都拉走，然后在阿根廷卖掉吗？英国人回答说：行啊，太好了。于是他带着所有的废铁工人们进行了一次旅行，他们在岛上表现得非常糟糕。他们弄得一团糟，到处乱涂乱画，而且你知道的，英国南极考察队的人对此进行了投诉。他们弄得一团糟，到处乱涂乱画，而且你知道的，英国南极考察队的人——他们还烤了一头驯鹿，对吧？好吧，那是第二组，那是第二组，这行为太令人发指了。塔菲其实去了英国大使馆，他
can I come and take away all this scrap metal and sell it in Argentina? They were like, yeah, great. So he makes one trip with all his scrap metal men, and they behave very badly on the islands. They make a mess, and they put graffiti everywhere, and they just, you know, the people of the British Antarctic Survey complain about it. And they make a mess and they put graffiti everywhere and they just you know the people the british antarctic survey and they waste a reindeer right well that's the second that's the second group that's shocking behavior taffy actually went to the british embassy and he
进行了投诉，并正式道歉，说我们表现得很糟糕，这种事不会再发生了，我们能回来把剩下的废铁拿走吗？是的，于是他们又回来拿剩下的废铁了。现在，在此期间，似乎发生的情况是，阿根廷海军得知了他要去的计划，并说：我们会给你提供船只。你可以带上我们的一些人，你知道的，穿着某种准军事制服，然后他们就可以顺便占领这个岛。
complained and he formally apologized said we behave very badly that won't happen again can we come back and get the rest of the scrap metal yes so back they come to get the rest of the scrap metal now in the interim what seems to have happened is the Argentine Navy got hold of the fact that he was going and said, we'll give you ships. You can take some of our men with you, you know, in sort of paramilitary uniform, and then they can just seize the island.
那太棒了。那一定是个绝妙的恶作剧。英国南极考察队对此毫无办法。正如你所说，汤姆，他们在三月份去了那里，伪装成废铁商，然后烤了一头驯鹿。这引起了英国南极考察队的注意，他们是一群留着胡子的公开大学学者，
And that's great. That'll be a great hoot. There's nothing the British Antarctic Service can do. So as you say, Tom, they go along in March, disguised as scrap metal dealers, and they barbecue a reindeer. And this draws the attention of the British Antarctic Survey, who are sort of open university men with beards,
研究企鹅或做其他什么研究。他们翻过山脊，看到这些穿着军装的家伙在吃驯鹿，于是他们发回了一条消息，先是发给福克兰群岛，然后发给伦敦，称这种行为极其恶劣，哪怕按多米尼克的标准来看也是如此。我昨天在读你的书，你知道的，我和你做过很多播客，所以我非常适应你的语言节奏和怪癖。当我读到关于烤当地驯鹿——那是一种受保护的物种——这一句时，甚至以南美废铁商的标准来看，这也显得相当糟糕。
studying penguins or whatever they're doing, who come over the ridge and see these blokes in military uniforms eating reindeer and they then send a message back initially to the Falklands and then to London saying absolutely disgraceful behavior even by the standards of Dominic I was reading your book yesterday and I you know I've done a lot of podcasts with you so I'm very well attuned to your verbal rhythms and idiosyncrasies. When I read this sentence about the roasting of the barbecuing of local reindeer, which was a protected species, even by the standards of South American scrap metal dealers, this seemed pretty poor form.
我当时想，只有……这真是标准的桑德布鲁克式句子。嗯，这确实很糟糕，汤姆。无可辩驳。是的，你不能到处烧烤驯鹿。好吧，这很糟糕。这把阿根廷的计划彻底搅黄了。
And I thought only... That is such a Sandbrook sentence. Well, it is poor form, Tom. It is, indisputably. Yeah, you can't go around roasted barbecuing reindeer. Okay, so that's bad. And that snarls up. The art of time plan, completely.
是的，所以他们不得不提前行动。基本上发生的事情是，南乔治亚岛这场闹剧的消息传回了伦敦。许多托利党议员，以及工党，都愤怒至极，对这种旷世丑闻感到奇耻大辱。是的。所以下议院里有大量的叫喊声：把这些废铁商赶出去，他们在偷我们的岩石，呃，
Yeah, so they have to go early. So basically what happens is news of this South Georgia fiasco gets back to London. And a lot of Tory MPs, but also the Labour Party, are absolutely berserk, absolutely disgraced by the show on Earth. Yeah. So there's an awful lot of shouting in the house of commons get rid of these scrap metal dealers they're stealing our rock um
所有这些都在伤害我们的驯鹿，没错，确实如此。他们有——外交部派出一个软弱无能的大臣发表了一篇演讲，所有人都对大喊大叫。而在旁听席上，坐着一个来自阿根廷大使馆的人，他向布宜诺斯艾利斯发回了一份报告，上面写着：天哪，英国人已经发现南乔治亚岛发生的事情了。这绝对会把我们入侵福克兰群岛的计划彻底搞砸。于是阿根廷军方在26日——我想是的，或者25日、26日开了一个大会。他们举行了一系列会议。
all that's doing our reindeer right exactly and they have and and the the foreign office put up some feeble minister who gives a speech and and everybody shouts at him and in the gallery is a man from the argentine embassy and he sends a report back to Buenos Aires saying, oh my God, the British have found out what's going on in South Georgia. This is going to absolutely mess with our plan to invade the Falkland Islands. And so the Argentine military have a big meeting on the 26th, I think it is, or 25th, 26th of March. They have a series of meetings.
他们基本上对那些负责制定行动计划的人说：你知道你们打算在秋天进行的那个行动吗？你们能在基本三天内完成吗？他们回答说：没问题。所以在3月26日，军政府做出决定：好吧，我们现在就入侵，如果我们再拖延下去，英国人就会派人——他们会去处理南乔治亚岛的事情，那里会有很多船只。事情会变得一团糟。我们必须马上行动。这非常像俄罗斯和乌克兰的情况。在3月28日，他们告诉所有的征召兵，
They basically say to the people planning the operation you know that operation you're going to do in the autumn can you do it in basically three days and they say sure so on the 26th of march the hunter make the decision fine we'll invade it now because if we leave it any longer the british will send you know they'll be in they'll be dealing with south georgia there be lots of ships. It'll be a mess. We've got to do it right away. And so it's very Russia and Ukraine. On the 28th of March, they tell all their troops who are conscripts,
你们要去进行一次非常大型的军事演习。他们把他们全部装上运兵船，船上还有一箱箱的阿根廷国旗，供他们分发给岛民。有些新兵相信，岛民们会非常高兴摆脱英国的统治获得解放，因为他们之前就是这么被告知的。英国的枷锁。是的。英国的枷锁。
you're going on a very big exercise. They load them all onto these troop ships, and they've crates of Argentine flags for them to hand out to the islanders, who some of the conscripts believe will be delighted to be liberated from the British because that's what they've been told. The British yoke. Yeah. The British yoke.
于是他们扬帆起航。而英国对此一无所知。英国政府在福克兰群岛的代表是一个叫雷克斯·亨特爵士的人。他是个了不起的家伙。我喜欢雷克斯·亨特。他是个了不起的家伙。我喜欢雷克斯·亨特。你在书中这样描述他——再次声明，这些引文太精彩了，我忍不住要引用——一个直率、快乐、矮壮的家伙，就像在彼得·塞勒斯喜剧中扮演英国殖民地总督一样。
And off they go sailing. And the British have no idea that this is coming. The representative of the British government on the Falklands is a man called Sir Rex Hunt. He's a splendid fellow. I love Rex Hunt. He's a splendid fellow. I love Rex Hunt. Who you describe in your book, again, quotations are so good I can't help but cite them, a bluff, jolly, stocky fellow as if playing a British colonial governor in a Peter Sellers comedy.
是的。所以雷克斯·亨特就是这样——没错，雷克斯·亨特五十岁出头。他是个个子不高的家伙。完全是这样，汤姆。他看起来就像那种演员，专门扮演某个鸟不生蛋、根本没人真正关心的孤岛总督，就像《滑稽戏》里的福克兰群岛版本，是的，因为他会由西德·詹姆斯扮演，由西德扮演，他肯定会由西德·詹姆斯扮演。所以雷克斯·亨特绝不是外交部的明星，有人曾在某个
Yeah. So Rex Hunt is this, right, so Rex Hunt is in his mid-50s. He's a sort of short fellow. Exactly that, Tom. He looks like a man who plays the governor of some some you know godforsaken island that no one's really that bothered about carry on the falkland island yeah because he's played by sid james paid by sid he would be played by sid james so rex hunt is not a star of the foreign office by any means and somebody has some said at some
时候说过：我们拿老雷克斯怎么办？噢，好吧，把他派到斯坦利港去，把他派到福克兰群岛去，他会喜欢那里的。雷克斯·亨特喜欢飞行，他想，我可以在那里进行大量的业余飞行。于是他带着妻子梅维斯去福克兰群岛担任总督。他们住在这种维多利亚式的——看起来有点像维多利亚式农舍的建筑里，这就是总督府。他干得非常非常出色，不是吗？他棒极了。他开着一辆红色的出租车，一辆伦敦出租车，那是他的公务车。基本上他要做的所有事情就是审判羊只、审判毒品案件，邀请岛民们来家里吃晚饭，跟人们握手，做一个友善的人，喝喝茶。所以这感觉就像在一个……
point what will we do with old rex no well send him to stanley send him to the falklands he'd love it out there and rex hunt likes flying and he thinks well i can do a lot of flying amateur flying and he goes to the falkland islands to be the governor with his wife mavis and um and they live in this sort of victorian it looks like kind of victorian farmhouse which is the kind of governor's house and he's very very good at it, isn't he? He's brilliant. He drives a red taxi, a London taxi, which is his official vehicle. It's just basically all he has to do is judge sheep drug trials and kind of have groups of the islanders over for dinner and just sort of shake people's hands and be a sort of friendly guy, drink cups of tea. So it's like being kind of local laird in a...
完全一样。边境地区。边境或者类似的地方。情况完全就是这样。而且他干得很出色。外交部曾对他说：如果你能告诉这些家伙，他们的未来在于阿根廷，那就太好了。
Exactly. Borders. The borders or something. That's exactly what it is. And he's very good at it. The foreign officer said to him, yeah, it'd be very good if you could tell these chaps their future lies with Argentina.
事实上，当他到达那里后，他完全被福克兰群岛同化了。所以他入乡随俗了。所以他入乡随俗了。外交部对此非常不满。所以，我的意思是，这个故事太不可思议了——所以在周三晚上——我想那是三月的最后一天，当地的法官退休了，雷克斯·亨特邀请了福克兰群岛的要员（虽然也没几个）共进晚餐。他们观看了一部关于福克兰群岛的电影，
And actually, when he gets there, he is completely converted to the Falklands. So he goes native. So he goes native. And the foreign officers are very displeased with him. So, I mean, the story is incredible so on the the on the wednesday night so i think that's the the last night in march the local magistrate had retired and rex hunt had had the bigwigs such as they are of the falklands over for dinner. And they'd watched a film about the Falklands,
是一部关于他们自己岛屿的独立电视台纪录片，名叫《比英国人更英国》。他们非常喜欢。他们觉得这简直太棒了。片中讲述了他们如何空运罐装spam午餐肉，还有玛氏巧克力棒以及诸如此类的东西。所以他度过了一个美妙的夜晚。他起床了。他的儿子托尼从寄宿学校回家了，
an ITV documentary about their own islands, called More British Than the British. And they loved it. They thought it was absolutely brilliant. It was all about how they had tins of spam flown in and they had Mars bars and all this sort of stuff. So he's had a big night. He gets up. His son Tony is home from boarding school,
他们终于让托尼完成了他的项目或作业，这是个好消息。他处理了一些文件，上面写着今天是星期四，他吃了午饭——你知道的，梅维斯、托尼、雷克斯和加冕鸡。然后到了3点30分，办公室设在总督府的无线电操作员走过来敲门，他说，我们刚刚收到这份电报。电报上说，我们有确凿的可靠证据表明，阿根廷特遣舰队将于明天一早（4月2日）在彭布罗克角外集结。您将需要做出相应的部署。这是从哪里发来的？这是从英国发来的吗？这是从伦敦发来的。
and they finally got tony to do his project or his work so that's good news and he does a bit of paperwork it says thursday he has lunch you know mavis tony rex coronation chicken um and then at 3 30 um the radio operator whose office is in government house comes and knocks on the door and he says, we've just had this telegram. And the telegram says, we have apparently reliable evidence that an Argentine task force will gather off Cape Pembroke early tomorrow morning, 2nd April. You will wish to make your dispositions accordingly. And is that coming from, that's coming from British? That's coming from London.
是的。这基本上就相当于：哦，顺便说一句，你们明天早上就要被入侵了。你知道的，做你们该做的事。而雷克斯·亨特，在此之前从来没有过——他迎来了自己的泽连斯基时刻。这就是当时的情况。所以他基本上说：好，烧毁所有机密文件。他到处打电话。他说：取消明天的学校。那里有69人的皇家海军陆战队守备部队。他告诉他们，他们说，好吧，我们将在这里的总督府——这座巨大的维多利亚式建筑里组织防御。于是他把梅维斯和托尼打发去跟一些朋友住。当然，这是在他们吃过晚饭之后。所以他们还是留下来吃晚饭了。他们吃了晚饭。这非常具有滑稽剧的风格。
Yeah. So that's basically like, oh, by the way, you're about to be invaded tomorrow morning. You know, do what you have to do. And Rex Hunt, who up till this point has never had, he has his sort of Zelensky moment. This is what this is. So he basically says, right, burn all the classified papers. He rings around. He says, cancel the schools for tomorrow. There's a Royal Marine garrison of 69 people. And he tells them, they say, well, we'll mount our defense here in government house in this sort of big Victorian house. So he sends Mavis and Tony off to stay with some friends. Although not until they've had their dinner. So they still stay for dinner. They have dinner. So that's very carry on.
他们吃了一顿家庭晚餐。然后他们动身去朋友家，海军陆战队现在正在开进来，搬运他们所有的装备。雷克斯去拿他的猎枪，当他去拿的时候，他发现他的司机——那个开出租车的人——已经在那里了，比他先到一步，正在给枪装弹。这个司机对他说：长官，我今晚把国旗升着呢，我会射杀任何试图把它取下来的阿根廷混蛋。雷克斯·亨特深受感动，不得不转过身去掩饰自己的眼泪。他觉得这是多么了不起的时刻。但随后，这是整部福克兰群岛史诗中最让我感到
They have a family dinner. Then they go off to stay with friends the marines are now moving in moving in all their kit and rex uh goes off to get his shotgun and when he goes to get it he finds that his chauffeur the man who drives the taxi is there got there before him and is just loading it and the driver this driver says to him i've left the flag up tonight sir and i'll shoot any argy bastard who tries to take it down and rex hunt is so moved by this that he has to turn away to hide his tears he thinks this is such a splendid moment so but then this is the single detail the entire forum's epic that i find
最不可思议的一个细节：他随后上床睡觉了，睡了一觉。你本以为大多数人都会紧张得瑟瑟发抖，但雷克斯·亨特没有，他去睡觉了。他在凌晨两点或三点左右再次醒来，现在这里到处都是皇家海军陆战队员，他手里拿着枪。他又收到了一份来自外交部的信息，外交部说：我们试图请求罗纳德·里根出面调解与阿根廷人的冲突，但没有结果，阿根廷人正在赶来。然后在大约早上5点，雷克斯听到了巨大的巨响和爆炸声。阿根廷人显然已经登陆，他们向海军陆战队开火了。
most extraordinary he then goes to bed and has like a sleep and you would think that most people would be shaking with nerves but rex hunt no he has a sleep he wakes up again at sort of two o'clock in the morning or three in the morning the place is now full of royal marines and he's got his gun um he has another message from the foreign office the foreign office say we've tried to ask ronald reagan to intercede with the argentines but no joy the argentines are on their way. And then at about 5am, Rex hears these colossal bangs and explosions. The Argentines have clearly landed, and they've opened fire
突然之间，他身处其中。周围到处都是枪声，他们基本上被围困了。伴随着这个字面意义上的重磅炸弹，我认为我们应该暂停一下。明天继续讲述这个扣人心弦、宏大史诗般、英勇悲壮又带有喜剧色彩的故事。
on the Marines. And suddenly, there he is in the middle of it. There's all this shooting going on, and they're basically under siege. And on that literal bombshell, I think that we should take a halt. Continue this gripping, epic, heroic,
所以我们明天见，我们将讨论福克兰群岛是如何陷落的以及伦敦的反应是什么。太棒了。大家明天见。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家番外、提前解锁、无广告畅听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。
comic narrative tomorrow. So we will see you tomorrow and we will talk about how the Falklands fell and what the reaction was in London. Brilliant. See you tomorrow, everybody. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦花边的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、番外节目以及——本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐往事》。这是您每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、少量娱乐圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想收听无广告的音频、独家番外节目，目前本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。